Jeff Bezos of Amazon exposes the
National Enquirer as a blackmail racket
the Democratic green New Deal gets off
to a bit of a rough start and we check
the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show remember like a
thousand years ago to remember a
thousand years ago when President Trump
gave the State of the Union address you
remember that that was awesome right but
that was like a thousand years ago cuz
so much has happened since then and a
lot happened yesterday as well we'll get
to all of it in just one second first
let's talk about an uncomfortable fact
you're gonna die right we're all gonna
die we're all gonna plotz and when we do
we want to make sure that our families
have money left to take care of them
the best way to do that is to get some
life insurance but what do you know
about buying life insurance do you
understand life insurance well enough to
buy it
well if you don't you need to check out
policy genius they've created a website
that makes it easy for you to compare
quotes get advice and get covered policy
genius is the easy way to get life
insurance in minutes you can compare
quotes from top insurers and find the
coverage you need at a price you can
afford
from there you just apply online and the
advisors at policy genius will handle
all the red tape they'll even negotiate
your rate with the insurance company no
extra fees no Commission sales agents
just helpful advice and personalized
service and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy whether you're
shopping for disability insurance to
protect your income or homeowners
insurance or auto insurance they can
help you get covered fast so no matter
how much or how little you know about
life insurance you can find the right
policy in minutes at policy genius.com
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
them out right now over at policy genius
again just apply online the advisors at
policy genius handle all the red tape
for you no extra fees no commission
sales agents go check them out policy
genius.com don't be buried in a pauper's
grave check them out policy genius is
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance all righty so the big news of
yesterday is that Jeff Bezos went to war
went to war with the National Enquirer
now to be perfectly accurate the
National Enquirer first one to war with
Jeff Bezos now you'll recall that Jeff
Bezos is the owner of both Amazon and
the Washington Post and he has been in a
running gun battle with President Trump
for legitimately 3-4 years now over
president Trump's politics president
Trump's belief that the Washington Post
is a smear machine against him and so
president from has reveled in all of the
allegations about Jeff Bezos and all of
the new information that be Soze was
his wife with his next-door neighbor and
now they're gonna get a divorce and his
wife is gonna walk away with a hundred
and seventy billion dollars or something
well now it turns out that the National
Enquirer was trying to blackmail B's O's
they had obtained photos and text
messages of B Zoe's his crotch basically
and then they went to be Zoe's and they
said we'd like for you to stop using the
Washington Post to investigate us or
these photos might unfortunately leak
well B so's then just basically said all
right well if you want to play this game
here we go and he just unzipped and put
everything on the table so yesterday in
a very long post for medium.com
he wrote No thank you mr. pecker that
there is something unbelievable about
the fact that the owner of the National
Inquirer is named pecker which led to
the headline in the New York Post as
well as The Huffington Post today B's
owes exposes pecker which is a fantastic
fantastic headline here is what Jeff
Bezos posted he said so first of all
just word to the wise
don't blackmail a guy worth a hundred
and seventy billion dollars who also has
the capacity to create 2-day delivery
for anything right and has drones like
squads have drones that work for him
it's just gonna go very poorly by the
way it turns out the main distributor
for the National Inquirer owned by
amazon.com okay so here is what here's
what he says be Zoe's something unusual
happened to me yesterday actually for me
it wasn't just unusual it was first I
was made an offer I couldn't refuse or
at least that's what the top people at
the National Inquirer thought I'm glad
they thought that because it emboldened
them to put it all in writing rather
than capitulate to extortion and
blackmail I've decided to publish
exactly what they sent me despite the
personal cost and embarrassment they
threatened am i the owner of the
National Inquirer led by David Packer
recently entered into an immunity deal
with the Department of Justice related
to their role in the so-called catch and
kill process on behalf of President
Trump and his election campaign mr.
pecker and his company have also been
investigated for various actions they've
taken on behalf of the Saudi government
and sometimes mr. pecker mixes it all
together after mr. Trump became
president he rewarded mr. Packers
loyalty with the White House dinner to
which the media executive brought a
guest with important ties to the Royals
in Saudi Arabia at the time mr. pecker
was pursuing business there while also
hunting for financing for acquisitions
that is from an article
I believe the Washington Post federal
investigators in legitimate media have
of course suspected and proved that mr.
pecker has used the Enquirer and Ami for
political reasons and yet Ami keeps
claiming otherwise American media
emphatically rejects any assertion that
it's reporting was instigated dictated
or influenced in any manner by external
forces political or otherwise of course
legitimate media have been challenging
this assertion for a long time and then
he has a list of sources he says I
didn't know much about most of that a
few weeks ago when intimate text
messages from me were published in the
National Enquirer I engaged
investigators to learn how those texts
were obtained and to determine the
motives for the many unusual actions
taken by the Enquirer as it turns out
there are now several independent
investigations looking into this matter
to lead my investigation I retained
Gavin de Becker I've known mr. de Becker
for twenty years his expertise in this
arena is excellent and he's one of the
smartest and most capable leaders I know
I asked him to prioritize protecting my
time since I have other things I prefer
to work on and to proceed with whatever
budget he needed to pursue the facts in
this matter
perks of being a billionaire here's a
piece of context my ownership of the
Washington Post is a complexify er for
me it's unavoidable that certain
powerful people who experience
Washington Post news coverage will
wrongly conclude I am their enemy
President Trump is one of those people
obvious by his many tweets also the post
essential and relents unrelenting
coverage of the murder of its columnist
Romano shaggy is undoubtedly unpopular
in certain circles back to the story
several days ago and am i leader advised
us that mr. pecker is apoplectic about
our investigation for reasons still to
be better understood the Saudi angle
seems to hit a particularly sensitive
nerve a few days after hearing about mr.
peckers apoplexy we were approached
verbally at first with an offer they
said they had more of my text messages
and photos that they would publish if we
didn't stop our investigation my lawyers
argued that ami has no right to publish
photos since any person holds the
copyright to their own photos and since
the photos and themselves don't add
anything newsworthy that is the case by
the way the Peter teal and Hulk Hogan
made against Gawker and basically it
bankrupted Gawker a.m. eyes claim of
newsworthiness is that the photos are
necessary to show Amazon shareholders
that my business judgment is terrible I
founded Amazon in my garage 24 years ago
and drove all the packages to the post
office myself today Amazon employs more
than 600,000 people I will let those
results speak for themselves
okay back to their threat to publish it
intimate photos of me I guess we me my
lawyers in cavenda back
didn't react to the generalized threat
with enough fear so they sent this and
then the chief content officer he pastes
an email from the chief content officer
of ami to the litigation counsel for
debecker about Jeff Bezos and it says
Marty I am leaving the office for the
night however in the interest of
expediate in the situation and with the
Washington Post poised to publish
unsubstantiated rumors of the Washington
Enquirer his initial report
I wanted to ascribe to you the photos
obtained during your news gathering in
addition to the below-the-belt selfie
otherwise colloquially known as a bleep
Peck The Enquirer obtained a further
nine images and then they described the
images including including images from B
so Stu his lover whose name is Sanchez
and pictures of his crotch and all the
rest B so says that caught my attention
but not in the way they likely hoped any
personal embarrassment am I could cause
me takes a backseat because there's a
much more important matter involved here
if in my position I can't stand up to
this kind of extortion how many people
can on that point numerous people have
contacted our investigation team about
their similar experiences with AMI and
how they needed to capitulate because
for example their livelihoods were at
stake in the ami letters I'm making
public you will see the precise details
of their extortionate proposal they will
publish the personal photos unless Gavin
de Becker and I make the specific false
public statements of the press that we
have no knowledge or basis for
suggesting that a.m. eyes coverage was
politically motivated or influenced by
political forces if we do not agree to
affirmatively publicize that specific
lie they'll say they'll publish the
photos and quickly and there's an
Associated threat they'll keep the
photos on hand and publish them in the
future if we ever deviate from the lie
be assured no real journalists ever
propose anything like what is happening
here I will not report embarrassing
information about you if you do X for me
and if you don't do X quickly I will
report the embarrassing information
nothing I might write here could tell
the National Enquirer a story as
eloquently as their own words below and
then he just dumps out over emails so
here is why this is relevant number one
a.m. I was being used as to go-between
by President Trump during the campaign
to pay off various women and that
obviously has been reported on the dot
that has yet to be connected and the one
the media are jumping on here is the
suggestion that President Trump both
hates the Washington Post and used ami
as a go-between
so maybe the reason that ami was going
after B Zoe's is because B Zoe's was
going after Trump so BAE
basically a.m. I was afraid that bees
dose was gonna discover some sort of
corrupt relationship between the Saudi
government and am I on the one hand and
Saudi government and the Trump
administration on the other and his
corrupt triangle colluded together to go
after Jeff Bezos and then a.m. I tried
to blackmail diso's to that notion
apparently debecker has now been telling
reporters that he thinks that bees does
his text message were actually obtained
maybe by a government source meaning
that the phone wasn't hacked
instead government data gathering
allowed the Trump administration to grab
these text messages and then hand them
off to AMI obviously if that's true
Trump gets impeached right Amin if
that's true then it's the end of the
road for the Trump administration using
government resources in order to grab
the text messages of your political
opposition in the report Oriole field
and then blackmail if that would be the
end of the line for president forget
about impeachment II to go to jail right
I mean that that's an actual crime for a
variety of reasons but beyond that
they're trying to now connect us that
have not yet been connected nobody
really understands why am I was going
after BSO's it doesn't make a lot of
sense Trump going after B says makes
sense in the sense that Trump doesn't
like B says he rails about him routinely
he calls it the Amazon Washington Post
he's been going after B's O's for years
on Twitter but the idea that ami was
blackmailing B's owes to stop reporting
about their connection with the Saudi
government were they doing that on their
own if they were doing it on their own
it just demonstrates what we've already
known which is that ami is basically
just a payoff organization and is used
by various rich people in order to shut
down stories they don't like also they
blackmail people right this is this is
pretty well note all of this is gonna
come out we're gonna find all of this
out because remember that David pecker
and ami are currently in a plea
arrangement with the Southern District
of New York in the US District Attorney
for the Southern District of New York
they are in a plea arrangement by which
they are obligated to cooperate with the
Southern District of New York so if you
think that all of this is gonna stay
secret it is not I will say this all
credit to be sauce really like I you
know I'm a fan of Amazon I think it's a
great company I was one of the first
subscribers to Amazon Prime I've been a
member of Amazon since like 1998
but putting aside my own business
interest in this journalist blackmailing
people people blackmailing people
generally he's really disgusting and
trying to suggest that you're going to
reveal
personal information about someone
unless they do what you want is not only
a violation of law it is a breach of
basic human decency so good for binos I
mean the man can't afford to do it and
honestly what does he have to lose at
this point like people are gonna see his
his junk what does he care he's the
richest man on planet Earth
so what really I assume that he has the
same junk everybody else does and he's
feeling the same way so honestly good
for B's nose good for B's owes a lot of
people today are saying well be so
Sprott this on itself because he was
cheating on his well that's true right
all that's true in terms of you
shouldn't be sending text messages of
your junk to other people you shouldn't
be cheating on your wife all that's true
that is a separate issue from should
personal issues be used by journalistic
purportedly journalistic organizations
to blackmail you the answer of course is
no so good for be soz for exposing that
that's good for the country and frankly
it's good for it's good for the world I
mean that is just it's well done by Jeff
Bezos they're all credit to him all
right in a second I'm gonna get to the
botched rollout of the green New Deal by
the Democrats because it is pretty
wonderful we'll get to that in just a
second first let's talk about the debt
you have racked up and how you can solve
it for decades credit cards have been
telling us to buy now and pay for it
later with interest despite your best
intentions that interest can get out of
control pretty quickly with Lending Club
you can consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you
and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Ben check that
rate in minutes borrow up to 40 grand
that is Lending Club com /ban once again
Lending Club comm slash Ben all loans
made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender check them out Lending
Club com slash Ben ensure that you are
able to pay off that debt that you've
been racking up and you haven't been
doing enough about again check them out
at Lending Club at comm /ban where you
can check your rate in minutes and
borrow up to 40 grand once more
Lending Club comm / Ben go check them
out right now as I say all moans made by
web bank member FDIC an Equal Housing
lender
all right so final note on the ami saga
so ami has now announced that they are
going to
do an investigation of themselves so
OJ's gonna search for the real killer
that is that is very exciting stuff from
AMI
obviously it means nothing but there are
other shoes that are going to drop here
here's the statement American media made
in response to Jeff besos he said
American media believes fervently that
it acted lawfully in the reporting of
the story of mr. B's owes further at the
time of the recent allegations made by
mr. B's sauce it was in good-faith
negotiations to resolve all matters with
him
nonetheless in light of the nature of
the allegations published by mr. B's
house the board has convened and
determined that it should promptly and
thoroughly investigate the claims upon
completion of that investigation the
board will take whatever action
appropriate action is necessary okay
he's not making claims he literally took
her emails and published them that's the
whole thing that's not a claim that's
evidence so ami has got some serious
troubles of its own okay meanwhile I am
highly amused by the reaction of
everyone to AO sees green New Deal so if
you didn't listen to yesterday's show
you should go back and listen to
yesterday's show where I broke down in
full detail AO sees green new deal there
was a resolution put forward on the
floor of the house that was basically a
series of aspirational motions about
what we should do with the energy
industry in the United States and then
AOC had the temerity to put online a six
page summary of all the things the green
New Deal stood for this was a very bad
thing as it turns out because it turns
out that a OC and her team have the
combined brain wattage of a kumquat it
was I mean the document is just
astonishing it is one of the worst
political documents I have ever seen put
together by human hands it's it's
incredibly stupid in every every aspect
and yet and yet it was endorsed by every
single top Democrat running for
president of the United States Cory
Booker Spartacus he said excited to join
AOC and Senator Ed Markey on a historic
green New Deal resolution to address the
peril of climate change and worsening
inequality our history is a testimony to
the achievement of what some think is
impossible we must take bold action now
and then for some reason people started
drumming in the background just like in
his campaign videos real weird senator
Elizabeth Warren says if we want to live
in a world with clean air and water we
have to take real action to combat
climate change now I'm proud to join a
OC and Senator Markey on
Green New Deal resolution to fight for
our planet and our kids futures because
I want to paint with all the colors of
the wind and senator Elizabeth Warren
and then you had and then you had Kamala
Harris the the brilliant newcomer from
from California who spends her days
going after the Knights of Columbus and
spends her evenings going after gang
rape allegations against Brett Cavanaugh
says I am proud to co-sponsor AOC and Ed
Marquis green New Deal
we must aggressively tackle climate
change which poses an existential threat
to our nation and that wasn't all
there's one more we also had Kirsten
Gillibrand who said a greener deal is
ambitious it's bold and I'm
co-sponsoring this resolution with AOC
and Senator Markey because it's exactly
the kind of action it will take to
conquer the biggest threat of our
lifetime also I'm against the resolution
but I'm also for the resolution but I'm
against the resolution and also for the
resolution Kirsten Gillibrand with her
typical savoir faire and stolidity in
support of her ideals so all four
senators who are currently running for
president on the Democratic side endorse
the green New Deal Bernie Sanders had
nothing to say about it he was busy
presumably eating pudding so all of them
endorsed this and none of them
apparently have read anything else he
has to say and what's even more amazing
is the media have not asked any of them
though they support what's in a OCS
actual statement remember AOC sponsored
it every single one of those tweets
mentions AOC because she is the fresh
face so fresh so face none of them have
been asked none of these senators have
been asked about her proposals to for
example replace all air travel by rail
including presumably from Hawaii which
led mazie Hirono the senator from Hawaii
who is a Democrat to say what now are
you that like huh and then the proposal
says that we should pay for full
benefits retirement vacation for anyone
unable or unwilling to work she says we
should retrofit or replace every
building in the United States in the
next 10 years she says that we should
get rid of cow farts by getting rid of
the internal combustion engine
all of this was put in writing we went
through the entire document yesterday
like word for word and it's funny
because then you have the media coverage
which is don't take her seriously don't
take her literally just take her
seriously
we shouldn't take aoc literally even
come on come on why would you why would
you read her words and then say she
means the words that she read that she
writes why would
you possibly do that here's politico's
headline the impossible green dream of
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez the green New
Deal will never happen the way it's laid
out and that's also kind of the point
what now well since when does somebody
propose legislation like it's not gonna
work the way they say it will but that's
exactly the point it's like when you go
to a modern art museum and it's just a
blank canvas like what is this and like
it's nothing and you're like well then
what does it mean it means nothing
that's the point okay except there's a
policy proposal so Michael Grunwald is a
senior staff writer for political
magazine let's get real the United
States is not going to achieve Net Zero
greenhouse gas emissions in ten years
the key goal of the green New Deal
resolution unveiled Thursday more
realtalk Americans won't get a hundred
percent of its power from zero emission
sources within a decade either another
audacious green New Deal goal and we're
not going to upgrade the energy
efficiency of every single building in
the country as the resolution proposes
if we were getting all our energy from
zero emission sources it wouldn't even
make sense to try but here's one more
reality check none of it matters the
official rollout of the green New Deal
on Thursday was met with a barrage of
skepticism from well-intentioned
fact-checkers badly intentioned climate
trolls and desperate to look savvy
pundits all focusing on logistical and
political impossibilities of
transforming the economy as rapidly as
the green New Deal envisions and they're
right its goals really do seem
impossible to achieve but they're all
missing the point if anything they're
hoping the green New Deal's backers make
their point which is that climate change
is an unprecedented emergency okay no
that's that's actually not what happened
here this is basically just a it's just
a version of Republicans pounds that's
all this is it's a versions uh it's a
version of AOC put out something so
ridiculously stupid that it makes her
sound as though she was dropped multiple
times on her head as a baby I mean this
is this proposal is so bad it can only
have been written by somebody who is
mentally deficient in some way it is it
is a it is a seriously ridiculous
proposal on its face on its face no sane
person could think otherwise
and so the comeback from the media is
well you guys are pouncing because the
real point is to open minds that's the
real point is to make you think to make
you think you know it's a it's a thought
it's a conversation so it wasn't meant
sir
really you know like sponsored
co-sponsored by six six senators and
sixty Congress people no it wasn't meant
seriously it was meant to open your mind
and broaden your horizons I'm sorry this
isn't this isn't some sort of trip to
Europe junior year of college this is a
legislative proposal that envisions
redoing the entire United States economy
by the way if we were to do all the
things in this proposal you know it
would do to climate presumably nothing
seriously nothing because if you
actually speck out the impact on climate
if the United States were to achieve
full zero emissions you know what
happened over the course of the next
century it would lower the time of the
global temperature according to the IPCC
by something like 0.2 degrees Celsius
why because it turns out that the real
threat to the climate if you believe in
climate change manmade climate change
the real threat to the climate is coming
from not industrialized countries at
this point but developing countries like
China in India who have no interest
whatsoever
in lowering their emissions so none of
it makes any sense but that's not the
only idiotic media take today there's
also the New York Times which can always
be counted on to cover for the stupidity
of Democrats in the reporting we'll get
to that in just a second first let's
talk about how you protect your internet
usage let's talk about your online
security and privacy so maybe you're one
of these people who has things that you
don't want people to know about like you
wouldn't want American media
international actually coming after you
well maybe you actually want to protect
your data from hackers and spies I don't
want my emails compromised or my credit
card number or online backing passwords
stolen out even have pictures of my junk
out there yet that happens to hundreds
of millions of people every year so how
can you protect yourself the company I
trust to defend my online security and
privacy is expressed at VPN expressvpn
secures and anonymizes your connection
by encrypting 100 percent of your
network data and hiding your IP address
that means nobody can record or access
your online activity download the
Express VPN app on your computer or
smartphone and then just use the
internet the same way you normally would
you click one button in the expressvpn
app voila you are now protected
expressvpn it's great for accessing
content from anywhere with VPN locations
in 94 countries and blazing fast speeds
as well an express VPN is consistently
rated the world's number one VPN service
for Internet users so if you want the
best in online protection you want to
free yourself from worries about hackers
and spies just head on over to
VPN the nice folks had expressvpn have
now extended special pricing of less
than seven bucks per month to all of my
fans so visit expressvpn comm slash bend
to claim that discount again that is
expressive VPN comm slash been to learn
more again
they are consistently rated the note
world's number one VPN service at for a
reason and it operates in the background
of your computer seamlessly it's not
going to slow up your computer because
they've got blazing fast speeds and VPN
locations in 94 countries you have
nothing to lose pricing a less than
seven bucks per month express it VPN
calm slash pen to claim your discount
again that is expressed VPN calm slash
been to learn more go check it out right
now okay so we read you politico's take
here's the New York Times's take you
ready for this on this idiotic plan that
legitimately says we're going to pay
people not to work quote Liberal
Democrats formally call for a green new
deal giving substance to a rallying cry
now you may be wondering did AOC write
this piece for the New York Times no she
didn't actually it turns out it's
written by Lisa Friedman and Glen thrush
both top notch reporters at the
wonderful incredible New York Times
listen again listen to to how this is
covered Liberal Democrats put flesh on
their green New Deal slogan on Thursday
with a sweeping resolution intended to
redefine the national debate on climate
change by calling for the United States
to eliminate additional emissions of
carbon by 2030 the measure drafted by
freshman representative AOC and senator
ed markey of massachusetts is intended
to answer the demand by the parties
restive base for a grand strategy that
combats climate change creates jobs and
offers an affirmative response to the
challenge to core party values posed by
President Trump the resolution has more
breadth and detail and is so ambitious
that Republicans greeted it with
derision well no actually we greeted it
with derision not because it's ambitious
but because it legitimately has no plan
for achieving anything that it says it
wants to achieve other than completely
destroying the United States economy
other than that it's great its
legislative prospects are bleak in the
foreseeable future Speaker Nancy Pelosi
of California has no plan to bring the
resolution in its current form to the
floor for a vote
according to a democratic leadership aim
why because Nancy Pelosi still has two
brain cells to rub together but listen
to listen to the New York Times as a
blueprint for liberal ambition it was
breathtaking
imagine the Republicans said we have a
plan here's our plan full employment for
everyone
taxes of zero and abolition of
7/8 of the federal government no details
just that do you think they would be
talking about how it's breathtakingly
ambitious you think that's where that
would go
it's breathtakingly ambitious your media
bias is so it I mean this is nauseating
nauseating stuff nauseating
now it's hilarious is that the New York
Times suggests that miss Pelosi Nancy
Pelosi is on the wrong side of history
people online yesterday it was delicious
I mean it was so delicious as neon
taster put it that it must be fattening
people online on the Left we're
suggesting that Nancy Pelosi is now a
climate denier because she was not
supportive enough of the green New Deal
but the New York Times reports Ms Pelosi
is likely mindful of her own past
mistakes
a decade ago she pushed the last major
climate change measure hard an ambitious
bill to cap emissions of climate warming
pollution she got a cap-and-trade
measured through the house the next year
Democrats were swept from power so now
she's afraid but she is letting her
critics and the on the Left know about
her own past efforts and saying she's
make climate change the flagship issue
of her first speakership proponents of
the green New Deal insist that Democrats
are unified Ocasio Cortes was said I
think it is a green dream because Pelosi
kind of dismissed yesterday Pelosi said
well you know I'm enthusiastic here's
what Nancy Pelosi had to say because she
again she's not a complete dolt when it
comes to you know running the Congress
here's what she had to say yesterday
about the green dream quite frankly I
haven't seen it but I do know that it's
enthusiastic and we welcome all the
enthusiasm that are out there the Green
Deal points out the fact that the public
is much more aware of the challenge that
we face and that is a good thing because
the public sentiment will help us pass
the most bold common denominator bold
initiatives I'm very excited about it
all and I welcome a very new deal and
many other proposals that people have
that okay what she actually means there
is I don't welcome the green New Deal
this is a very stupid thing but I'm
going to pretend to be enthusiastic
because I don't want people yelling at
me that's really what she is saying
there now what's hilarious about all of
this what's hilarious about all of us is
that a OC can't even keep her herself
straight on what exactly this
necessitates so yesterday yesterday
morning
she was asked whether in fact this green
New Deal would necessitate massive
government intervention and again yeah
for all the people out there saying that
she is savvy and smart I don't know what
to tell you I really don't I mean if you
are of the view that AOC is some sort of
brilliant newcomer I'm gonna play you
two clips in a row and you got to tell
me how exactly she's a genius here she
goes
saying that saying that maybe this might
necessitate massive government
intervention as you know congresswoman
one reason that people who are
politically conservative are skeptical
of efforts to combat climate change is
that it sounds to them like it requires
massive government intervention which
they just don't like are you prepared to
put on the table that yes actually
they're right what this requires is
massive government intervention it does
yeah I have no problem saying that fast
forward about six hours here is AOC with
Meet the Press is Chuck Todd one way
that the right does try to
mischaracterize what we're doing as
though it's like some kind of massive
government takeover obviously what we're
trying to do is well obviously it's not
that because what we're trying to do is
release the investments from the federal
government to mobilize those resources
across the country you know in the real
world we call that being a damned liar I
mean we just call that being a liar like
within six hours she goes from sure it's
a massive government intervention and
then after the blowback she's like well
no these Republicans they're pouncing
they keep characterizing it as a massive
government takeover it's on the massive
government takeover some massive
government intervention but sorry sorry
I shouldn't say that it's not a massive
government intervention
it's unleashing investment it's
unleashing investment so we're all
supposed to take her seriously we're all
supposed to pretend she's not a damn
liar she's a damn liar because all you
have to do is read the words on her own
website which were so stupid that her
own campaign had to take them off her
website she memory holds her own six
page proposal yesterday but we're
supposed to believe according to the
media that's an act of genius and also
we are not supposed to ask Cory Booker
Elizabeth Warren Kamala Harris or
Kirsten Gillibrand about any of the
details in a SES proposal we're not
supposed to ask them about that
you know I very rarely get angry at
media bias anymore because it's just a
fact of the world it's just like the Sun
rising every morning but it is
absolutely stomach-turning how
disgusting the media are at their job
talk about the mainstream
Media who will not ask any one of the
top Democratic nominees how they feel
about things like partial birth abortion
they won't get an answer a straight
answer from any of the top Democratic
nominees about what should happen with
sexual assault allegations against
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax in
Virginia they won't ask any one of these
top Democratic nominees if they believe
that those unwilling to work should be
paid for unwillingness to work according
to a o'seas plan or why they think a
o'seas plan is so brilliant they're not
gonna be asked about a single detail to
abolish air travel they're not gonna be
asked about any of those things instead
we'll just get the New York Times
assuming that it's a breathtakingly
ambitious proposal and if we look at the
details it's because we are not looking
closely enough it's because we are not
looking closely enough because if you if
you push away all of the details if you
push away the thickets of details of
that six page proposal what you get to
is a gem a gem of genius which is that
we should care what absolute
unbelievable horse bleep or cow fart I
mean it's just it's it's unreal it's
unreal we're gonna get some more
Democratic insanity in in just a second
plus I want to talk about a sad piece of
news from the Supreme Court I'll get to
that in just one second first you're
gonna have to go subscribe over at Daley
we're calm for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe over it's a Lee Weyer when you
do you get the rest of this show live
you get two additional hours of me every
single day I mean we are working our
fingers to the bone every day to bring
you that show in the afternoon and I
will say it's pretty awesome we had a
lot of good fun with our subscribers
yesterday during the breaks I take
questions during some of the breaks and
it is a blast you're gonna want to be
part of that also you could have asked
us questions during the day Lee Weyer
State of the Union backstage we have one
coming up for the Oscars as well that's
going to be awesome and we have our
Sunday special which allows you to get
the if you're a subscriber you get the
last question of the Sunday special you
can't get it and also you get it a day
early so becomes the Saturday special
for you our next Sunday special guest is
another none other than the great Gary
Sinise and if you're a subscriber you
and only you can watch that episode a
full day early not only that all
upcoming Sunday special episodes will be
available on Saturday but only if you
are a daily wire subscriber so what
exactly are you waiting for click to
subscribe you will indeed thank me later
and again get the annual because the
annual is better than the monthly
because it comes along with this the
very greatest and beverage vessels the
long sought-after rarely obtained
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr only
one way to get it and that
to become a subscriber go check that out
right now also subscribe to us at
youtuber iTunes leave us a rating leave
us a review we always appreciated we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
one of the things that is so mad I mean
you feel like you're being gassed by the
media
it feels like you're being gassed late
it feels like they the term gas lighting
comes from an actual movie called
Gaslight in which a in which a woman
basically is driven mad by her husband
and the reason it's called gas lighting
is because what he does to drive her
crazy is every evening he lowers the
lights on the lamps and then he tells
her that the lights are not actually
lower on the lamps right he lowers the
lights on the lamps and then she looks
around she's like why does it seem dark
and Risa's it seems fine to me and the
whole point is to drive her crazy that's
what the media are doing every single
day and they are doing it particularly
about aoc because they're declaring her
the fresh face they're giving her 20
minutes on MSNBC this morning they are
pitching her they literally pitched her
all day on MSNBC they had a running
counter on the bottom of their of their
screen saying eight hours until we
interview the brilliant magnificent AOC
they put her on the covers of magazines
how many covers of magazines has Melania
Trump done recently I mean forget that
how many how many covers of magazines
has Elise Stefanik who is a very young
Republican congresswoman how many how
many has she done I choose first elected
at the age of thirty she's now 34 she's
also from New York have you ever heard
of her of course not but we've been told
that AOC is a deeply important figure in
democratic politics and then when you
comment on how dumb she is then it's
you're obsessed with her maybe if you
guys would I mean it's just gas lighting
it's just basic gas lighting so
Democrats are going to have to own a OC
you got it you broke it you bought it
guys you broke it it's yours now so
you're gonna have to own comments like
this here is a OC yesterday explaining
that ice should be abolished and does
not deserve one dime of funding we're
here to say that an agency like ice
which repeatedly and systematically
violates human rights does not deserve a
dime right they do not deserve a dime
until they can prove that they are
honoring human rights until they can
make a good-faith effort to expand and
embrace immigrants until they can prove
good faith to an American ideal they do
not deserve any resources for their
radical agenda okay unbelievable so
we're going to abolish ice but then she
goes even
and then she says you know what forget
about abolishing nice what if we just
didn't have a border basically what if
it turned out that everybody who is
descended from Latinos or from Native
Americans they can't commit crimes in
the United States let's just assume
everyone in the United States illegally
is not actually here illegally because
their ancestors were here before we were
so here is here she is legitimately
making the argument we didn't cross the
border the border crossed us right which
is a full-on Laura's a radical argument
here she is making that argument
yesterday publicly in front of
microphones but we're all supposed to
ignore it because we only pay attention
when a OC is on the cover of a magazine
smiling or when she's dancing on a
rooftop
we don't pay any attention to the dumb
crap that falls out of her mouth on a
regular basis we are standing on native
land and Latino people are descendants
of Native people and we cannot be told
and criminalized simply for our identity
or our status okay quick quick note
Latino people are not all descendants of
Native people if by native people she
means people who occupied the
continental United States there are lots
of there are lots of Latino people by
the way who are from you know like South
and Central America and whose ancestors
came from there so the notion that
everybody coming up from Honduras is
actually a descendant of a person who is
living in Arizona in 1722 is obviously
untrue but it's also a dumb argument
where a sovereign nation we have control
of our own borders but according to her
no will any of the other Democrats be
asked about that any of them of course
not one of the one of the great
annoyances that I have with the way the
media covered these things if a
Republican does something bad every
Republican is asked whether they agree
or disagree and is asked to own it or
disown it when a Democrat does something
bad then every Democrat is asked whether
they like cheese right they're just
random questions that have nothing to do
with the topic and they're never there's
no burning follow up questions so
yesterday for example Kamala Harris who
is the Democratic frontrunner for the
20/20 nomination she was asked about the
situation with Justin Fairfax in
Virginia who has now been credibly
accused of sexual assault and she says
that the accuser is credible but she
does not call for Fairfax's resignation
now the natural follow-up question would
be and should be weird because you
thought that Brett Kavanaugh should be
disqualified from the Supreme Court by
an accusation alone does that follow up
question happen of course not
the the letter written by the woman
reads as a credible account and I think
there should be an investigation to get
to the bottom of it and determine the
facts certainly her letter reads as it's
quite detailed and suggests that there's
credibility there but there needs to be
an investigation to determine what
exactly happened oh interesting an
investigation well I don't remember you
saying that an investigation would be
enough to exonerate Kavanagh in fact
there was an FBI investigation and found
nothing and then you still called for
him not to be put on the Supreme Court
so in other words lady you're a liar but
nobody asks you a follow-up question
because that's the way this nonsense
works Democrats can say whatever stupid
garbage they want to say six months ago
and then when they say precisely the
opposite no questions AOC can say two
opposite things in the course of eight
hours and there will be no follow-up
questions she can release a proposal so
bad that it makes a hamster look like a
great legislator
I mean that that proposal yesterday was
so bad you know that they say that uh uh
you know a thousand monkeys typing for a
thousand years might eventually be able
to type all of Shakespeare in a row no
monkeys would ever be able to create
that proposal given an infinite amount
of time it is too stupid for the animal
kingdom that proposal it is just dumb
okay but where any of the Democrats and
the Democrats openly owned it they
openly said I mean it's so it's so
maddening the Democrats openly tweeted
we love this proposal it's great and
then the proposal comes out and do the
media even ask them so how do you feel
about like a Bala Chanel travel how do
you where where are you on the issue of
paying people who are unwilling to work
where are you on the issue of a plant a
lot of trees that's what it actually
says where are you on cow farts what a
joke what a joke our media our I mean
serious no one takes them seriously and
they shouldn't take them seriously all
right you know let's let's get to some
mailbag because I need to calm down so
let's let's do some unrelated stuff for
a second oh yeah yeah it is it's it's
absolutely frustrating to see some of
the dumbest people in the world say some
of the dumbest things and then be feeded
as the smartest people in the world by
some of the dumbest people in the world
that that's a summary of our current
political situation
all right so mailbag time David says hi
been major fan I really
all the great work you do I go to UCSD I
had a discussion with my professor
regarding unconscious bias and
discrimination and I held that
affirmative action policies make
generalizations based on race that are
unnecessary given accessibility to
individual information of applicants he
directed me to a number of sociological
studies that seemed to demonstrate
racial discrimination in employment
hiring with the disparities in response
to white and black applicants being
statistically significant over the last
couple of decades well I can think of
some alternative explanations that can
explain away some of the relation the
data seemed to be reliable I was
wondering what your opinion was on this
sociological research I don't believe in
anti-discrimination laws I'm libertarian
but I'm not sure I can ignore some of
the data thanks for all you do okay well
a couple of quick things first of all
since I don't have the exact studies
that you are referring to here it's hard
for me to respond I don't want to give
short shrift to sociological studies
that I have not read I will say this the
sociological studies that are most often
cited things that suggest for example
that people with black first names get
hired less often than people with white
first names are ignoring other studies
that also suggest that if you use black
last names and white last names there is
no discrimination in other words what
people are discriminating against is an
assumption that may or may not be
justified about culture and not an
assumption about race per se in other
words if you were to receive an
application from a Jewish person and it
were to say on the application you has
go as a first name and then you were to
receive an application from a Jewish
person just a David you might treat
those two applications differently
because you have skill probably implies
the person keeps Sabbath and it's not
going to be able to work from Friday
night to Saturday night for example
that's because one is a Hebrew name and
one is a name that also applies in
English the same thing can apply to
first names so if that's the study
you're talking about that's my response
to that study as far as the
anti-discrimination law my feeling is
that if people are being dumb enough not
to hire productive black citizens then
that's a competitive advantage for a lot
of businesses that are willing to hire
competitive black citizens so I'm I'd
like to see the sociological studies
frankly before I analyze them again I
don't want to give short shrift to
studies that I haven't read that's sort
of the basic response and also again
affirmative action programs would not
actually counterman the in the
unwillingness to use individual data
very often people are using generalized
data about groups because they are not
allowed to ask about individual data so
for example the Obama administration
refused to allow federal Khan
tractors to ask about prior criminal
status for people they were hiring this
led to less black employment why because
a lot of companies were simply using
group data on prison statistics instead
of individualized data about whether
this person went to jail in the absence
of individual data Melissa says mr.
Shapiro my husband and I have very
different opinions on how the 2020
election will pan out I think that the
democrats have been united by such
loathing for trump that they will come
out in droves to vote in 2020 my husband
thinks that trumple defy all odds yet
again because that's just what he does
what do you think well I'm not a big fan
of the will defy all odds in spite of
data just because look there was a 70/30
shot that Hillary was gonna win the last
election that doesn't mean the 30
percent doesn't exist 70 percent is not
a hundred percent so it wasn't
impossible for Trump to win it was very
unlikely he would win and in fact he did
buck the odds by losing by two and a
half million votes in the popular vote
and then running an extraordinarily
narrow gauntlet its win three separate
states by a combined total of 80,000
votes
I think the Trump does have an uphill
battle with that said could Democrats
blow it you bet your ass they could blow
it there's a new poll out today from
optimist that shows that in a national
race between Donald Trump and Camilla
Harris it is Trump 45 Harris 44 all
Democrats had to do was not be bat bleep
insane and they just couldn't do it they
just can't stop themselves they are this
crazy and Michael says greetings mr.
Shapiro I'm writing an essay on common
stereotypes of conservatives and how it
is harmful to the group I seek your
advice on what you believe are those
common stereotypes well there's one that
has been put out by Erich Fromm it's
been used for now 60 years basically
suggesting that conservatives are
authoritarian that they have too much
respect for authority and therefore
they're big fans of government telling
people what to do that is a lie
conservatism is about limited government
we have respect for moral authority but
that does not mean that we have lots of
respect for governmental authority very
very different thing they're also
stereotypes about how conservatives are
racist and bigoted and sexist and
homophobic again those stereotypes are
unjustified by the realities but it is
simply a way for the left to suggest
that the politics with which they
disagree are ill motivated as opposed to
simple disagreement Stephen says hey man
what do you do to decompress when you're
frustrated this podcast right this radio
show I yell at people that's it but but
really what do I do well you know same
things everybody else does presumably i
watch TV i go home and i pract
violin and play music mostly I play with
my kids that's that's the best way to
decompress I put down my phone is
honestly the best thing you can do
likes thank God for Sabbath because
Sabbath is necessary Oprah says hello
Ben
have you asked forgiveness from Michel
Noel's at Yom Kippur for bullying him
for years no I pay him no why would he
should ask forgiveness for me
considering that his productivity has
significantly lacked behind what what
exactly we pay him he he owes me a
constant apology on a daily basis
Stephanie says hey Ben in your opinion
why do you think african-americans align
themselves with Democrats when largely
they are socially conservative
especially when it pertains to abortion
transgenderism etc well I'm not sure
that they are socially concerned about
abortion they are socially conservative
on same-sex marriage and transgenderism
is what I've seen from the polls not
sure that's the case on abortion
african-americans historically speaking
started to align with the Democratic
Party long before the 1960s Civil Rights
Act and welfare programs came into
effect they started to do so during the
FDR administration and then they
continued to do so over the years as the
Civil Rights Act and the Voting Rights
Act moved forward and mainly as a lot of
welfare programs began to come online
because why not I mean if you're
disproportionately receiving government
benefits then why wouldn't you vote for
an increase in those government benefits
but to suggest that that is solely due
to the politics of the 1960's is to
ignore the trend lines which began in
the 1930s of black Americans moving away
from the Republican Party and sort of
the Democratic Party in large numbers
Samuel says Ben how do you suggest young
people get involved in local politics
successfully well get involved in local
politics I mean here's the nice thing
about local politics no one cares about
them all you have to do apparently is
when fifteen thousand votes in a primary
and you become the most powerful
Congress person in America which is what
happened to Al C so local politics can
matter as long as you also under social
media savvy temper says hey Ben huge fan
I'm a senior at a private Catholic High
School today we were discussing poverty
and its causes and I being an outspoken
person brought up your points for how
not to stay poor in the United States
and how cultures in cyclical
poverty-stricken areas have reinforced
these bad habits my opponents insinuated
I was racist and my generalizations were
disrespectful to the poor any tips on
debating this issue and any good sources
I could reference yes I always reference
the Brookings Institute the Census
Bureau has numbers that prove that this
is the case every study ever done has
shown that single motherhood is linked
to intergenerational poverty and crime
and again when people suggest you're a
racist your first response should be
well you're a jackass because you have
no evidence I'm a racist you just want
to ignore the point of my argument it's
it's really a pathetic move by people to
say that when you say you know people
should make responsible decisions to
avoid poverty and then they respond by
calling you a racist that that's somehow
okay it is not okay it is nasty it is
gross and it is unjustifiable well as a
race says hey Ben there's a
seventeen-year-old conservative from
Vermont I was wondering how you think
Generation Z will affect voting in the
country over time since for our age we
are pretty conservative I know also many
others my age who are secretly
conservative I wonder if you think this
would affect polling data I think over
time it well I think there's a backlash
to the PC SJW culture mainly because
they're so boring and annoying honestly
there are there any less fun people than
the SJW class on college campuses and in
the media and people who make you feel
like you have to look over your shoulder
every minute of every day so that you
have not offended they're shifting moral
standards that apparently do not include
killing babies up to point of birth but
do include random microaggressions that
they just defined in the last two
minutes david says hey Ben thanks for
spending more than six hours of your
state-of-the-union Tuesday in front of a
camera for our pleasure best 99 bucks
I've ever spent
thank you David appreciate it I noticed
that Trump said me address his
administration was in negotiations with
the Taliban how if at all do we
reconcile this with the USA's policy we
do not negotiate with terrorists thanks
I don't think we can frankly I think
negotiating with the Taliban is a
mistake I think that we should have gone
in and we should have basically
installed a dictator and gotten out
because democracy is not going to
flourish in Afghanistan now you can
install a dictator who is friendlier to
particular rights that we hold dear this
is the case in for example Qatar the
United Arab Emirates
you know those areas of the world are
dictatorships that have respect for
certain basic rights like freedom of
religion in a way that a lot of
democracies so-called democracies that
camasta Stan and the Gaza Strip
obviously do not does that mean that's
the ideal no it's not the ideal but to
pretend that every culture and every
tribal situation is equally prepared for
democracy that will end with a
neoliberal style democracy is just
foolhardy and untrue Charles says I'm a
first year medical student who starts in
August how did you and your wife manage
loans from school are there any books
you recommend on the subject thanks love
the show I mean I'll be honest with this
I paid off my wife's medical school
loans
as we went I was already earning I was a
little older than she was so I was
already in the workforce and we spent an
awful lot of money as we went through
with me like paying off her bills we
went so she came out of medical school
debt-free but that is because we were a
couple already as far as taking loans
you know there there's some people like
Dave Ramsey who suggests that you
shouldn't take loans even for medical
school you should go out and work for a
few years build up your your you're not
basically and then go out and spend that
on medical schooling I'm not of the
opinion that that is necessary but you
know you find the lowest interest loan
you can and then don't get behind in the
payments if you have to take a side job
you take a side job Avery says I'm a
freshman at James Madison University in
multiple classes this year professors
have used the 2008 financial crisis as
evidence that the free market must be
regulated
they say the conservative governance
leading up to the crisis and the
deregulation of financial markets
directly caused the recession is this
characterization of events correct no it
is not correct okay deregulation of the
financial markets combined with massive
government intervention in the financial
markets is what caused this so the
United States does not have a full scale
free-market system it has closer to a
corporatist system in which government
policy skews incentives so to take an
example the subprime mortgage crisis
that was caused that melted down
beginning in 2007 and then extending
into 2008 that's caused largely by the
government guaranteeing loans from
particular from particular companies
because they wanted more minority
homeowners to get into houses at
subprime mortgage rate subprime
mortgages were created for people with
poor credit scores who wanted to get
into housing and the government propped
this up the government was happy to back
a lot of those loans through Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac and and then all those
went belly-up it turns out a lot of
people were going bankrupt now what
happened is that while there was still
demand that was artificially boosted by
the federal government then the basic
assumption made by the market forces was
okay well let's say we give a loan a
subprime loan and somebody doesn't pay
off the loan when we go back and we
seize the house we flip it and then next
week we sell it for more so we don't
actually lose money on the deal
that's only true as long as the market
keeps going up so they were slicing and
dicing all these subprime mortgages and
they were creating derivative products
where they were combining the subprime
mortgages with higher value mortgages
and then grading all of it a plus
basically and selling it on the open
market that's why it had ramifications
when all the subprime mortgages melted
down it took
down all these derivatives with them
those derivatives have been used in
trades by a variety of financial firms
and those financial firms went bankrupt
off the back end so when people say that
it was really about glass-steagall and
hedge funds being able to both invest
and also to do banking now it really
wasn't about that it was about the
government skewing the incentives and
creating a false bubble that eventually
burst because people were being told
that there was no consequence if they
put out a mortgage to a person who could
not pay back the mortgage it was Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac all the way that was
really involved in causing the subprime
mortgage crisis and then as far as
government intervention ISM it is
probably true that absent government
intervention ISM in order to save those
financial firms the fallout from the
meltdown is broader and wider it is also
true that maybe if that fallout had been
a little bit broader and wider it would
have taken down a lot of the
irresponsible financial firms but again
the problem with a government involved
system is that the solution very
offerman is very often unfortunately to
prevent further fallout is more
government involvement which is exactly
what happened okay final question let's
see mm-hmm
Amelia says hi Ben I've recently got
into an argument with someone regarding
the gender pay gap I told her that the
statistic she stated didn't include
factors like job choice hours etc her
about it was that further studies were
conducted they included these factors
and had the same determination I know
this is wrong but I want solid evidence
to prove my point I'm asking for a few
good resources I can turn to for this
argument well Heather McDonald has
written extensively about this Christina
Hoff Sommers has written extensively
about this I do not know of a single
study that takes into account gender
gender inequities in in job taking a
number of hours worked in time in the
workforce
I don't really really I don't know of a
single study that takes into account all
of those things that suggest that the
gender pay gap is for example 23 cents
on the dollar which is the which is the
proposal of many of the folks who are
pushing this nonsense okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today so
AOL sees green New Deal proposal is
basically the fire festival it's we're
all gonna party it up on a beach how
we're gonna pay for it we're not gonna
pay for it guys all you have to think
about is your shared prosperity that's
all that matters okay that was the pitch
of the fire festival so there's a great
documentary over at Netflix on the fire
festival app
titled fire here's a little bit of the
preview in the Bahamas the most insane
festival the world has ever seen
island getaway turned disaster it became
very far bear just wait until you see
what you're getting yourselves into
American rappers our rule isn't the
Bahamas with his business partner really
MacFarlane is an amazing entrepreneur he
could convince anyone of pretty much
anything they just bought an island
Pablo Escobar's Island oh my god we're
gonna do a festival yeah
within 48 hours they sold out these guys
are either completely foolish or they're
the smartest guys in the room oh well
then there you have it the green new
deal on an island basically everybody
ended up living in tents and beating
each other up four bottles of Avion
water so it worked out just spectacular
Lee over at the fire festival well done
everybody and I guess we can apply that
nationally now and we will call
basically AOC is Billy McFarland that
right hanging out with all the cool
people
genius sales person also complete fraud
but we're supposed to ignore all that
because it's breathtaking innit ambition
you know what else was breathtaking in
that ambition the fire festival it ended
quite poorly okay time for a quick thing
that I hate the thing that I hate today
I'm old enough to remember when people
like me meaning me when people like me
suggested that perhaps John Roberts
would be a bad pick for the Supreme
Court because he did not have an
established record on key issues and
then there were people like me who
suggested the Brett Kavanaugh also may
not have been the world's best pick for
the Supreme Court because his record was
a little bit spotty on certain key
issues like for example abortion well
now it turns out that the Supreme Court
has ruled in favor of the left in a key
case from Louisiana according to Ed
Morrissey over at hot air he says say
weren't five for decisions supposed to
go the other way now Chief Justice John
Roberts sided with the four liberals on
the Supreme Court to issue a stay on a
tough new abortion law in Louisiana it's
temporary but it's curious a divided
Supreme Court stops Louisiana from
enforcing new regulations on abortion
clinics in a test of the conservative
views and abortion rights the justices
said by a 5-4 vote late Thursday they
will not allow the state to put into
effect of law that requires abortion
providers to have admitting privileges
at nearby hospitals Chief Justice John
Roberts joined the courts for liberals
in putting a hold on the law pending a
full review of the case and then it
turns out that Brett Kavanaugh also
wrote in a dissent that the situation
was not ripe for the courts scrutiny he
said between us the case largely turns
on the intensely factual question of
whether three doctors can obtain
admitting privileges if we denied the
stay the question could be readily and
quickly answered without disturbing the
status quo or causing harm to the
parties or the affected women and
without this Court's further involvement
at this time so basically he his logic
actually spelled out the same logic as
John Roberts he just dissented but the
bottom line is it looks like Roberts and
Cavanaugh are the new swing votes on the
on the Supreme Court and that the
replacement of Kennedy with Cavanaugh
and the replacement of I'm trying member
who went down from Roberts to take over
but in any case the the the pudding of
John Rahu's Rehnquist I think was
Rehnquist rank was going down Roberts
taking over that's it not results in a
new right wing majority on the Supreme
Court or even a constitutionalist
majority on the Supreme Court and ended
up with to censor moderates who are now
a new swing block on the court so well
done everybody well done everybody we'll
find out the final result of this but
relying on the supreme court to protect
all your hopes and dreams when it comes
to the pro-life position is a fool's
errand
all right well we'll be back here later
today for two more hours we got a lot
coming up on today's radio show you're
gonna want to subscribe so you can
listen or listen live on your radio
station depending on where you live go
check that out otherwise we will see you
here next week make sure to tune in for
our Sunday special and subscribe so it
becomes a Saturday special with Gary
Sinise a world-famous actor and terrific
director go check that out we'll see you
here on Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19